bonjour avec six poulains merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
jean castex était inconnu du grand
public il est omniprésent depuis sa
nomination
son premier objectif est à l'air atteint
se faire connaître par tout le monde
partout des français oui bah ils
profitent effectivement des mois d'été
pour faire un tour de france médiatique
quasiment 20 jours sur le terrain sur ce
premier mois d'exercice parce
qu'effectivement à sa nomination jean
castex n'était pas connu du grand public
encore moins que edouard philippe
lorsque emmanuel macron l'avait choisi
pour être son premier premier ministre
donc il va occuper le terrain pendant
que le président est au fort de
brégançon pour les vacances ça lui
laisse le champ libre de se faire
connaître de voir aussi un peu dans les
régions quelles vont être les
partenaires pour la discussion tâter
aussi la température du terrain pour
préparer la rentrée sociale qui risque
d'être particulièrement tomber surtout
que jean castex avait une lourde tâche
un succès d un edouard philippe qui
était au sommet de sa cote de popularité
oui alors il ya eu des hauts et des bas
mais c'est vrai que edouard philippe a
choisi le moment de pur partir après
après avoir bon an mal an gérer cette
crise du virus fin faut rappeler que
l'on a attendu longtemps les masques on
a attendu longtemps des protections du
matériel de protection pour les
soignants des tests n'oublions pas que
la gestion par le gouvernement de cette
crise a été extrêmement pratique et nous
a conduit à ce grand confinement qui a
mis l'économie à l'arrêt aujourd'hui on
en paye le prix
donc jean castex oui arrive une serpe
avec des sondages d'opinion quitté au
point de voir philippe mais ça ne veut
pas dire grand chose tellement il était
fluctuant d'une semaine sur l'autre pour
lui maintenant l'enjeu est de se faire
connaître
et puis d'attendre de voir parce que
au-delà de la communication il y aura
les faits et les faits sont parfois bien
loin des discours
alors on parle beaucoup de la méthode
jean castex claire attentif à l'écouté
quelle est sa méthode sa méthode je
crois que c'est celle de la concertation
d'abord c'est celle de la discrétion
aussi on voit qu'il n'est pas forcément
un
un excellent communicant de jouer la
carte sans doute de l'entièreté savoir
on sait d'où il vient il a été
secrétaire de l'elysée sous nicolas
sarkozy ensuite il a son bilan en tant
que maire il a travaillé aussi avec
différents partenaires pour la
préparation des jeux olympiques
donc il a déjà un réseau c'est un homme
de réseau c'est un homme qui est plutôt
de l'autre côté de la lumière pas
vraiment dans la lumière donc c'est
nouveau pour lui il apprend vite
après il a un ton qui est effectivement
comme le disait un député un peu un peu
lent qui qui endort un peu et la
majorité et les parlementaires et les
français aussi donc il est là pour me
calmer tout le monde et dire rassurez
vous ça va bien se passer
alors vous le disiez un rentrée qui
s'annonce chargé un compliqué jean
castex ajustements dresser un la carte
des priorités avec en tête l'emploi là
on leur économique sociale la santé
l'écologie est ce qu'il aura vraiment le
temps de faire tout ça mais il n'aura
pas le choix surtout parce que la
campagne pour 2022 a déjà commencé en
réalité 600 jours c'est très peu et il
va devoir effectivement limiter la casse
à la fois sur les chiffres du chômage
qui risque d'être très nombreux
et puis et puis sur d'autres plans alors
sur l'écologie on voit déjà sa recule
sur les petites avancées on commence
déjà à mettre des échéances plus
lointaines
donc encore une fois ce sont les actes
on jugera sur pièces d'ici six mois
entre un premier bilan je pense de
l'action de ce nouveau gouvernement
entre les effets d annonce les plans de
communication et puis la réalité sur le
terrain
alors il ya des collectifs de gilet
jaune qui ont atteint une grande journée
de mobilisation dans toute la france à
la rentrée à partir du 12 septembre
là aussi on attend la réaction de jean
castex oui alors il n'y a pas que lui
emmanuel macron a aussi nommé vingtaine
de nouveaux préfets qui vont être là
justement pour bien être la courroie de
transmission de l'elysée dans les
territoires puisque en marche a perdu
les municipales et n'a pas réussi à
ancrer ce pas son parti dans les villes
donc ce sera une façon de
comment ça va être gérée au delà de la
mobilisation du 14 septembre pour
rappeler que j'ai jaunes sont toujours
actifs que la grogne sociale est
toujours forte en france pour attendre
d'autre réponse que celle qui avait été
donné le grand débat par exemple était
une façon d'endormir mais cette fois
c'était macron qui jouait devant les
caméras là il n'y a pas seulement ceux
ci mais il ya les nombreux plans sociaux
qui risque d'être de plus en plus
nombreux d'arrivée il y aura les accords
de compétitivité on va demander aux
salariés de renier sur leur salaire pour
sauver leurs emplois
alors on peut appeler ça négociations on
peut appeler ça prise en otage les
syndicats risquent d'être extrêmement
mobilisés pour protéger les droits des
travailleurs donc c'est en cela que la
rentrée sociale risque d'être très chaud
merci à merci poulin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le cofondateur du monde moderne et merci